chuyện tâm linh dùng mình TikToker phần 300
mili kể chuyện từng gặp ma cà rồng ngoài đời
khiến AI nghe xong cùng sởn gai ốc
liệu truyền thuyết về sinh vật tâm linh đó thực sự tồn tại
hôm đấy nhá là một buổi tối các bạn ơi
mình đang rửa 8 chill chill
mình đang rửa 8 chill chill ở trong nhà
mình đang rửa lúc đấy là tầm lúc ấy là tầm khoảng 11 giờ
mình đang rửa 8 thì mẹ mình lúc ấy
nhà mình là bán buổi sáng sau đó buổi tối thì
buổi tối thì mẹ mình sẽ đi về
hôm đấy là mẹ mình
mình đang rửa 8 mình đang hát nha hôm nay mình đang hát là
hôm nay hôm nay em mặc một chiếc váy rất đẹp
đi trên đôi giày một gót anh đã tặng
loài HOA khi xưa anh thích dừng
tự nhiên mình nghe thấy tiếng xào xạt xào xạt ở ngoài cửa
thì mình bảo quái lạ bình thường mình
mình mẹ mình đi về mẹ mình đóng cửa Cho mình í
thì mình sẽ không nghe tiếng gì đâu kiểu vậy í
hình như là mình thêm Chi tiết thôi mình vẽ đấy
mình vẽ thêm đấy
xong rồi hôm đấy mình thấy cái cửa chưa đóng
thế là mình đi Ra ngoài
mình đóng cửa thì lúc đó là 11 giờ rồi
mình bước xa ú xa phát ơi cái
các bạn ơi cái á cái người mà mình kể là ma gà rồng đấy
đứng ở trước mặt mình như này ví dụ đây là ma nhá
đây là mình mình đi Ra xong rồi như này
mình thấy lúc đấy tiếng nó đang hư
đấy các bạn ơi xong rồi nhìn như thế xong cái cái con đấy
nó đang ăn cái con ếch với có con nhái đấy
nó đang ăn như này
này đâu rồi mình miêu tả như nào nhở
đây ví dụ đây là con ví dụ đây là con ếch đi như này này
xong rồi cái mắt của nó bừng sáng đây các bạn ơi
xong rồi mình nhìn vào nó
mình nhìn vào nó một lúc mình còn sợ lắm
tại vì là mẹ mình kể Cho mình
tại vì lúc đó mình bị say xe
mẹ mình bảo là mình đi về nhà với mẹ mình đi
ý là buổi tối đấy mẹ mình bảo mình mẹ mình
mình với mẹ mình đi về nhà
nhưng mà mình bảo là mình không SAO mình
đừng lo mình không say đâu à nhầm
ý là mình say xe lắm đừng lo mình ở đây mình không sợ đâu
thế mẹ mình cứ dọa mình là ở đây có ma đấy ở đây có ma đấy
xong mình bảo là không sợ không sợ
xong rồi mình không tin mẹ mình đâu mọi người
xong lúc mình nhìn thấy này
xong mình bị đứng hình xong mình bảo chết chết
xong mình bị đứng hình như này
mình sợ lắm xong mình bị bình tĩnh à
ấy xong bắt đầu mình đi vào trong nhà mình sợ lắm
xong mình mà dám đóng cửa lại
thế là cả một buổi tối đấy mình vừa sợ
mình vừa nghĩ lời mẹ mình nói
người ta bảo là sợ lắm đấy
đừng kể rồi
cứ bắt người ta kể xong rồi kể xong thì bảo thôi là xong